es el fin de un tenso y largo camino los
expertos del oiea liderados por el
director del organismo rafael grossi
llegaron finalmente a la central nuclear
de sabor y allá su objetivo evaluar los
daños causados por la guerra y evitar un
posible accidente nuclear
la misión que había llegado ayer a la
región de sap orilla provenientes de
kiev se retrasó varias horas en
desplazarse al punto exacto donde se
ubica la central debido a los intensos
combates que se libran en enero dar
este jueves a unos 5 kilómetros de la
planta se produjo una explosión que
causó la paralización de uno de los
reactores de la central pero como es
habitual en la guerra tanto rusia como
ucrania se responsabilizan
por supuesto estamos preocupados por una
provocación del lado ucraniano dado que
los bombardeos bárbaros y provocadores
no se han detenido vemos ese y otros
intentos de desestabilizar la situación
el director del comité internacional de
la cruz roja que se encuentra en ucrania
alertó sobre el riesgo de los ataques
próximos a la central nuclear a want to
express me gustaría expresar mi
preocupación por los combates que tienen
lugar dentro o cerca de la central
nuclear de sabor' y allá cuando los
sitios peligrosos se convierten en
campos de batalla las consecuencias para
millones de personas y al medio ambiente
pueden ser catastróficas y durar muchos
años
pero el kremlin insiste en negar su
responsabilidad de los ataques y asegura
estar haciendo todo a su alcance para el
correcto funcionamiento de la planta el
oiea ha expresado su intención de
establecer una misión permanente en la
central nuclear más grande de europa